yeah what's up I love you that's the  first time you've ever taught me that  whoo did I ever tell you how much I love  you  [Music]  don't tell you personally wouldn't if  you have forgotten  oh no good anymore  [Music]  are you looking for someone grandma we  will see the son of scram have you seen  her mom's mom's not here  don't you remember anything  I know you don't want to hear this is  hooking up with him dad I spoke to a  doctor thought it might be a good idea  if he came in to see him why well  because I can't read what can I do  better  step inside his world so he feels needed  tell me again how you met grandma you  met in Venice right how could I forget  what if we went together  you gave me no hair what you are doing  for your grandfather is extraordinary  if you like orientation  every one last time  [Music]  when my day comes remember  [Music]  you